evening everyone good evening councilors
and welcome to this meeting of the
council
I am councilor Catherine Grandin
chairman of baber District Council and I
will be chairing this meeting today
my first fall remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following a
fire exit signs a meet on the Ipswich
Town Football Club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silence
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except whether a confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you're also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May recalled film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
I'll now move to the agenda
apologies for absence
thank you chair I have received
apologies for absence from cancerous
Ayers hardacre Holt Newman Norman and
Creswell
councilor Barrett
thank you
item two Declaration of Interest by
councilors
are there any Declarations of Interest
thank you
item three
paper BC 22 32
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 25th October 2022 for accuracy
only
I refer you to the tabled papers
are there any issues with accuracy
councilor Barrett
um just I want to clarify item 1.1c
that no counselor will be entitled to
claim more than two sres
one SRI
yeah I guess it did used to be one SRA
so that's another increase
that's been put through is that correct
but the minutes are correct in that
respect
thank you
are there any other
questions about accuracy
thank you could I have a proposal then
please
councilman McLaren
can I have a seconder please
councilor Hinton
thank you all those in favor we'll have
a show of hands please
thank you that's carried
item four
paper BC 2233
announcements from the chairman and
leader
a refer you to paper BC 2233 for noting
um and I just wanted to re mention
um that on the 28th of January
I'm having a Chairman's dinner in eight
of my charity the blossom appeal at the
Royal Hospital School invitations will
be coming out shortly but I hope that
you might just want to put it in your
diary so you're ready it would be lovely
to see you there thank you
um and now I'd like to move on to
councilor Ward
um to make his announcements as leader
Council award
thank you madam chairman
all right it's amazing I'll be with you
in a second
no right
okay first firstly um
you'll all be aware now that
gainsborough's house finally opened to
the public yesterday and in the past
week it has received both local and
national news coverage
the facilities inside a superb and the
external architecture is really
impressive it's quite amazing to think
that a small town like Sudbury now has
something like this and I'm sure that
the economic benefits succumb for the
town will be huge it is the largest art
gallery and museum in the county and all
who have been involved with this project
should be immensely proud of what they
have achieved
he couldn't of course have happened
without the vision and drive of the
director Mark bills
the death of two-year-old awar bischak
after exposure to mold in his family's
flat in Rochdale was a tragedy
and I'm sure all members will join me in
expressing our sympathies to his family
this sad case has rightly put the
standard of social housing and spotlight
in the last week housing secretary
Michael Gove has written to all housing
providers in England including baber and
mid-suffer councils calling for an
urgent assessment of homes to provide
reassurance over standards
but we didn't have to wait for
government to act with this letter we've
already initiated work to address this
members will be aware that we initiated
a full diagnostic review of Building
Services earlier in the year
this picked up the need to increase our
input into resolving issues around mold
and damp
we have acted on these recommendations
this year for example we have trained
more people to deliver damp and mold
treatment and employed a damp specialist
surveyor
we're in the process of recruiting
another surveyor to increase capacity
the well-being of our tenants has always
been a priority following this case I
can promise members we will redouble our
efforts to ensure that the quality of
all our homes so that such a tragedy can
never happen again
I've spoken to our new housing director
Deborah Fenton who has updated me on the
actions already taken this year to
resolve any damp and mold issues and
further measures planned
we are also progressing well with our
stock condition survey and are
developing and costing a retrofit
program
the housing directorate will also be
developing a performance framework to be
presented to cabinets and the Tenant
board every quarter helping both members
and tenants to hold us to account
this work is just a part of what we're
doing to ensure our homes are fit for
the future and be rest assured councilor
Osborne is working hard with the
director of housing to ensure this
having contacted as soon as the d-lock
letter was received
last week the chancellor announced that
Suffolk had secured a Devolution deal
and that we would get an elected mayor
there will be additional powers and
crucially funding in areas such as
skills transport and housing
the County Council supported by the
other members of spsl has worked hard to
put together a proposal that the
government has now agreed to and this is
really exciting for the county
there has been some confusion about the
use of the term mayor and the
relationship between this position and
the County Council Administration
I have already confirmed that there will
be no change to the current leader
cabinet governance there apart from the
leader being directly elected and this
is dependent on the completion of the
leveling up and regeneration build with
its additional Provisions for alternate
alternative names to mayor I don't have
any more information yet but we can
expect further announcements in the next
few weeks
we will be publishing the baber end of
term report next week on the 28th of
November
this highlights what we've been able to
achieve during the past almost four
years
it has been a unique and challenging
time with covid and now the cost of
living crisis but you will see that
nonetheless a huge amount has been
achieved for our communities and
residents
it was completed with the guidance of
plg to ensure that it's non-political so
that all of us can use it as we wish to
put our own political spin on it perhaps
in the forthcoming elections
it will be an online document and we
will be able to help those without
internet access to read it at our
customer access points
I'd like to thank Jane Kennedy and
Francine tan for their hard work and
Gathering the information together and
to Brad Jones and Darren bird who have
done a fantastic job creating an
appealing and easy to read publication
thank you madam chairman
thank you Council award
unless um the only particular questions
we'll now move on to item five
to receive notifications
councilor Barrett
yeah just just on the uh question of the
uh situation regarding the elected mayor
um just for really clarification
so which are you saying that the
position of the of the mayor
will be elected and he will be the
leader of the County Council
I know it's a bit maybe above
the knowledge that we have at the moment
but it's just something that needs to be
clarified I think
councilor Hicks has made a statement in
public to the effect that we will be
having an elected County leader within
the current County's leader cabinet
governance model
and that's all I can say on that
work we won't be using the term later
yeah sorry
I'm going to be a floor in that so you
could have for example an independent or
green or liberal doubtful but it could
happen and then you could have a a
council of a majority of conservatives
is that the situation you've been I mean
it's sort of similar to baber really but
I mean it's um
it's something that we could actually go
is that what we could find ourselves in
I know it's not really your area but
it's it's clarification I think it's not
and I can't say anything further make
any further clarification all I can say
is what's been stated in public so far
thank you councilor Barrett that's all
that's known at the moment so
we'll now move on to item five
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with Council procedure rules
thank you chair none received
thank you item six questions by the
public in accordance with Council
procedure rules
I refer you to the question in the
tabled papers
the question has been redirected to
councilor Busby Cabinet member for
finance
I would like to invite Mr Riley to ask
his question Mr Riley would you like to
step forward please
[Music]
that's about to be great nice to see you
sir it is
you're looking so prosperous
how's the party there we are so the
audit of the 2020 and 2021 uh accounts
uh has been considerably
all by our supplementary
so it was due to problems with the
orders results allocation or other
issues with the accountants
you know what's holding up the front
edge what was holding up the
finalization of the accountants please
thanks Brian for your question
um it's the delays been caused by
resourcing within the actual Auditors
it's a it's a common problem over 90 of
the councils across the country uh are
late with their return
um
as far as your second part which is a
concerning any issues there are no
issues that we've been made aware of by
the old
the audience thank you councilor Busby
Mr Riley would you like to ask a
supplementary question it has to be
relevant to the first
Madam chair I always ask relevant
questions so uh the account show for
Auditors expenses that there's almost a
double
charge
apparently you're on last year on the
previous year for certification
are they doing more work for us or is it
like it was when we had uh Rivers Banks
all those years ago when documentation
was not in order what's caused the
increase
[Music]
councilor Busby would like to respond
I'd love to respond I'm not saying I'm
able to respond
um I couldn't give you the exact answer
of that uh we will be looking at that
and I can come back to you
okay with you
I'm afraid that's all you have the
opportunity to say for now Mr Riley
thank you
um you'll be
yes you will get it you will you'll get
you get a personal reply
thank you Mr Riley
thank you Mr Ray well now uh continue
with the agenda
item seven questions by councilors in
accordance with Council procedure rules
thank you chair none received
thank you item eight to receive reports
from cabinet members
I would like to invite councilor Ward to
introduce his report cmu1
Cabinet member for economic growth
Council award thank you madam chairman
um I'm not going to go through the
report in detail you've got it there in
front of you it's a very comprehensive
report and well presented and it
contains a very good summary of all of
the excellent work that's been done by
the economic development team just a few
things I'd like to highlight
um the innovate to elevate scheme which
we've launched this year is is something
which I think is going to be of great
help to many of our businesses it's
launched in partnership with the
University of Essex
jointly funded with them and they'll
provide the expertise to help businesses
who wish to look at novel business
practices and Technology to to innovate
and and grow that way
we've referenced again to a house I've
spoken about that already
um we would further work continuing on
the mixed use scheme at Hamilton Road
there is progress on this but everyone
should be
very aware that this is a very complex
scheme and it's going to take a lot of
time to to develop and put and come up
with something that is going to be a
viable
asking to take forward for Sudbury
what is um progressing much more rapidly
is the the work on the work site the
roadside development at Hadley on the
1871 the commercial units there and that
is something which is very exciting on
the land that we acquired from
Persimmons in a perfect location
alongside the bypass there
the solar PV panels at Kingfisher
they're generating electricity which is
excellent and the carports now have been
completed there was a huge amount of
delay while we waited for the inverters
to come from China and they were then
held up at Felix surgery in the recent
doc strike but all that's behind us now
and those have been installed
virtual High Street is going from
strength to strength still which is
excellent and is spreading out into the
villages and the innovate local market
schools stall scheme and Hadley is still
very popular it's been very very
effective and we're very pleased with
how
um helpful that has been for Hadley
businesses
finally I just wanted to summarize I
think and just let people know that Lots
has been done but some projects of
course are taking time they are deadly
difficult to deliver but we're not going
to shy away from doing the difficult
things because of the benefits that they
will ultimately bring to the district
and our residents
thank you madam chairman happy to take
questions
so there'll be no debate but they come
thank you
um the lead of the council um you
commented on page 14 on most of them you
did leave 84.8 the barrel View Park
um can you tell us if there's any more
information on the planning application
that came forward that was refused
whether it's coming back in another form
do you know or whether they're going to
appeal
um or what the state of play is thank
you
I have no further update on Bellevue at
this moment
councilman Clarin
um
one question uh John on 4.2 on page 12.
um
when the Kobe
Bridges were put out nationally there
was a lot of
noise about possible fraud and I see
here in 4.2 that we're undertaking some
audience on that is it too soon to know
the auditing outcome of of any potential
fraud in the applications from
businesses thank you at the moment we
don't have that information but I'll let
you know as soon as we do get it
thank you councilor Hinton
thank you madam chairman
um
Council Ward on page 16 paragraph 5.1 he
talks about work started on tendering
packs for changing Place facilities of
flatford mill
after securing funding for 45 000 from
government
as this is in my ward and I have no
absolutely not
tell me what an actual fact is going on
and how it was put forward in the first
place
uh I'm sorry Council engine that you you
weren't informed about this um and that
is an admission and um I can only
apologize for that
um we won a total of 90 000 pounds grant
funding for two changing places uh
facilities one at flatford Mill and one
in Bellevue Park in Sudbury and we're
progressing with the facility in
flatford Mill
councilor Lindsay
it was really just to question the
figures I think there's a comma
Australia in the wrong place in 5.6
uh
bringing in one
I don't know whether that's
one million or what that is exactly
that is one million
um and uh
two thousand and fifteen pounds
so
so it's just over a million pounds
so it's a missing naught thanks no no
the commas the comma should be after the
two not before the two oh yes yeah
thank you thank you any further
questions
thank you
right in that case no further questions
so I'd like to now invite councilor
arsie to introduce his report thank you
councilor arthi
thank you chair firstly I would probably
apologize for the fact that it's not
quite as slick as the one that's gone
before it I will do something about that
if I have to present another one I'll
get some charts and graphs and stuff
like that in four years so it's not
quite as colorful I do apologize
um you have it in front of you so I
won't repeat it all but I would like to
focus your attention on two key areas of
achievement
firstly chair the neighborhood planning
mentioned in paragraphs 3.9 and 4.5
we have now sorry we now have 13 adopted
neighborhood plans and another awaiting
referendum there are nine more at
various stages of preparation some of
them well advanced
I know how much time and commitment is
involved and congratulate all of the
people who put those plans together
the parishes with adopted plans have the
most up-to-date planning policies at our
disposal and their value has been proved
in planning decision making and tested
at appeal
and I want to express my thanks to Paul
Bryant our neighborhood planning officer
for doing so much to support the
communities making these plans
secondly I want to bring your attention
to community infrastructure Levy
mentioned at paragraphs 3.1 3.2 and 4.2
since its introduction we have collected
over 17 million pounds which includes
2.6 million of Parish neighborhood seal
the last 12 months have presented some
collection challenges and I am delighted
we now have a dedicated seal debt
recovery officer Debbie osak to ensure
we collect all the sill that is due
we must have the funds to support the
provision of infrastructure in those
communities accommodating growth
through the bidding process we are also
able to help areas where there is a
current infrastructure deficit
I must thank Christine thurlo for all
her help to get us to where we are and
Debbie osak for her unwavering pursuit
of sale payments
Christine and Debbie are here I don't
know if any of you or many of you have
met Debbie Debbie can you put your hand
up
Debbie and Christine I'm sure you all
know they're here this evening to answer
any detailed questions any of you may
have on Cell demands seal payments and
debt recovery
I also want to thank those members from
across the council who've helped steer
the sill framework through annual review
to ensure we adapt to meet the funding
requirements of the much needed
infrastructure
able is supported or is that led by
Christine Thurlow the still working
group has been one of the most agreeable
and supportive groups I have been on
thank you to the current members that's
Mary McLaren
Lee Jameson and Peter beer
and to all of those previous and to all
of those previous members that have
helped establish such a sound face for
our framework
thank you Council
that's a question yes thank you
councilor Barrett
um yeah my question is uh
no I'll leave a question to the last if
I make some observations before I get to
the question yes
yes I'm not debating
yeah
so we have a local plan I noticed that
councilor Arthur didn't actually say
much about the local plan because if I
was here might be very embarrassed about
my position on the local plan
it's late
it's been Rewritten it's failed to
address many areas that we require in
this District
it's not delivering houses and the level
that we need to deliver
and again I hear that we are now calling
for sites again having done this twice
since 2017 again resource Henry what is
going on with a local plan why are we
calling for sites when that work was
done and it was developed and put into
documents and it went out to the
communities as well that's your question
and yet we still find ourselves behind
the curve
counselor Aussie and so my question is
huh
when are we going to see a local plan
that is delivered that is relevant to
the district of baber
not mid-suffolk because obviously we've
got a joint local plan and I think baber
residents deserve to know what they're
getting I'm not interested in
mid-suffolk I'm interested in favor
at the moment I think baber is well
behind the curve and I think we need
some serious answers because we're not
getting them
cups are asking like to answer that
firstly it's a shame that cash
we spoke a bit about the situation with
regard to the Joint local plan when we
were looking at the um the local local
delivery scheme I think yeah
so I'm
well I'm afraid you weren't here to
listen to that were you because you well
you decided that you'd rather not attend
so we did have a little bit of a
discussion on that
um I think there are a couple of things
to say firstly
um I'm as disappointed as Council
barities that we're this far down the
road without having got to the final
modifications for what's going to become
a part one I said at the last meeting
that I feel as though I was charged with
with a job back in 2000 2019
um
haven't been able to deliver what I was
hoping to be able to deliver for John
Ward our leader I will say though that
we did deliver the submission document
by by December 2020 which was Our
intention
um that was submitted in early 2021 and
from that date onwards we have been in
the hands of the inspectors
so the decision to move to a part one
and a part two of the plan was something
that was agreed with the inspectors we
are now getting to the the final part of
modifications through
process for part one his question is
when will we I think he means finally
adopt
that's the word delivery
the intention is that with a fair wind
and the agreement of the inspectors if
we can keep to a timetable we are hoping
to deliver part one next year and part
two of the plan hopefully will follow
the following year
and that I think is the answer to your
question
thank you councilor Aussie
Council Barrett uh thank you Catherine
Arthur um uh there wasn't much that you
said last time apart from turning around
feeling a bit nervous that there was no
one on this side of the chamber for
obvious reasons
um what I would say is I think it's
pretty poor yes you delivered a plan to
the inspector but that plan actually was
not relevant and he virtually kicked it
out because he said it's not doing the
job that we require it to do and that's
why it's have to be sent back
um after massive changes to that which
you oversaw I believe
um from the original Bill Newman's
submission which was actually quite a
good document and for some reason that
was changed we don't know why it was
cherished
sorry and I'd like to why was there why
was there a change in the sense of
direction from a balanced approach to
development in most of the villages
through the call for sites to then
submitting most of the development
around the urban areas and only the
urban areas so it's out of its Rich
Fringe capacity Mary Coronado Sudbury
who initiated that change councilor
Arthur
um
I think that it was the outcome of
preferred options paper
um you're going back now to 2017 I think
um I would remind you that when the
submission document came to Council in
2020 a majority of council supported it
seal
can you allow councilor RC to answer his
question not count sell with an S but
can't sell with a c councilor Barrett so
the majority of this Council supported
and I believe you did as well perhaps
you were one of the few that didn't and
that was our submission document it was
based on all of the evidence that we'd
gathered it was based on the response to
all of the consultations that we'd done
through the through the
two years
and that's what we approved it was
during covid I remember I presented it
from my home and my screen went white I
remember that
and that was our submission document
it's not my submission document that I
made up it's a submission document that
was approved by this Council
just to clarify a point I was the
council in 2020
. so it definitely would not have been
me voting for it
if I had been there I would have
held you accountable
I'm sorry about that I'd forgotten that
councilor Barrett had two years when he
um he he wasn't on the council
okay
right if there are no further questions
um
councilor Parker
yep thank you very much Cher um I'd just
like to endorse the words of uh
councilor Arthur with regards to the the
success story that has been sill uh in
particular and it's uh delivered
enormous benefits to many of our
communities
um I know not least in in my own Parish
of Newton we've had a substantial
Grant of Sil money which is transformed
um the the Leisure and play equipment
over at Newton it's a beacon for others
to follow but
um I I am just a little bit concerned
with regards to paragraph 3.3 uh that
talks about the Civil debt recovery with
more than 245 000 pounds of outstanding
civil debt recovered which is laudable
and and Well Done
um but what is the total amount of debt
um that that is outstanding and and if I
may as well the question for councilor
Arthur is there any sense at all it's
showing that our planning office is on
here but is there any sense at all that
where developers renege on what is known
contribution at outside is there any
sense that there can be in some sort of
almost like a penalty or prohibition for
those developers coming forward that
want to uh to to make further
developments having reneged on their
initial uh obligations thank you
but I want to introduce Debbie osak to
um probably give a more full response
the figures that I have are up to the
end of September where there was about I
think half a million pounds of
outstanding debt that Debbie was dealing
with um
paid but if I could ask Debbie to
probably fully answer that question
a daily basis because obviously more
demand notices are issued payments
become due at the moment the figure is
not much above 500 000 outstanding we
have had some significant successes in
the fact that we issued a liability
order reminder notice to accompany to
take them to court and they actually
paid before their Court to due date and
that was just a recent one not one from
last year
so for the debt recovery side certainly
we are not backwards in coming forwards
and we'll try everything at our means to
recover that sum of money our last
resort is always to go to court we don't
want to get there we want them to pay
before that but we have got cases going
too cool and we will continue down that
process to secure the liability orders a
court order for them to pay
thank you any more questions if not
we'll move on with the oh cancer arthi
answer and that is that I hope you will
all support the fact that we are
committed to recovering every penny of
silt that's due on developments that
take place
um so there are small amounts and there
are some large amounts that Debbie uses
her best Endeavors to recover every
single penny
thank you councilor arthi
so now we'll move on to the next item on
the agenda and if there are further
questions
thank you item nine counselor
appointments are there any changes to
placings
thank you
item 10 motions on notice
item 10 a
to consider the motion on notice receive
from councilor Lindsay
Council Lindsay would you like to move
your motion
sure yeah
um thank you chair
so I I think
I probably don't need to spend much time
explaining
uh the problem we have but perhaps I
should perhaps it's right that I I
should admit
um
back in July Chris Whitty
um the national public health officer
produced a a statement sorry the chief
medical officer at Chris witty
um
along with both what
um and the environment agency
which highlighted the issue
and and he made the point that I mean
I'll quote his his words use of our
Rivers for recreation and exercise is
something to celebrate and encourage
children have always played in waterways
and always will irrespective of what
notices are put up next to them
people of all ages use freshwater
waterways such as Rivers for recreation
including swimming and various forms of
boating
doing lockdown many people took the
swimming in rivers and have continued
since our Rivers seas and waterways
should therefore be free from sewage
to address to reduce risk to the public
and you only really have to go to
Sudbury on a weekend to see
Stone to see the number of people
lots of people
should bear in that River
um but he Chris witty and others have
acknowledged
uh there's now a serious issue with the
storm overflow drains that water
companies and sewage companies have
produced they were meant they were built
in the 50s they were meant as an
emergency measure when there was a heavy
storm or really exceptionally heavy rain
it allowed sewage to spill into the
river we'll see
when they put monitors on a few years
back on some of these sites they showed
that sewage was it wasn't happening on
an exceptional basis it was happening
hundreds of hours during the year
um
and what we need is the water companies
to put proper money rather than uh
immediately returning all profits to
shareholders as angling water recently
paid 91 million out to its shareholders
it really should be spending on uh
improving its infrastructure and the
management of its sewage so our rivers
are not contaminated in a safe again
um the details of this motion uh
let me just get the thing in front of me
um I think that the idea is
we as a we as a council yes we don't
have we can't change planning policy
and and we can't demand that water
companies tell us
uh when there's a big development
whether they've got capacity in sewage
treatment
but we can ask and we can Spotlight the
problem
because the problem is no one else
is is uh is monitoring water companies
to ensure that this investment happens
and happens in a timely manner
um and angry water made the right noises
they say they want to invest in cleaning
up
um these storm overflows uh in reducing
the amount of time that they spill out
raw sewage into the rivers and so this
is a way of encouraging them to do that
um but I'm I'm using words carefully
like encourage because we don't have a
statutory right to demand that they
nor do we have
um the right in planning terms to refuse
applications just because uh angling
water haven't provided us with
information but we do have the right to
ask and I think it's important
just to Spotlight this issue and bring
pressure to bear
on angling water to say what they to to
to to encourage them to do what they say
they want to do
thank you
thank you may have a second though
please Council Ward thank you
um and you want to reserve your right to
speak or do you want to speak now yes
Council Ward yeah just say a few words
now in support of um of this motion of
councilor Lindsay's um
I think we're all it shouldn't be a
political thing or a partisan thing
we're all must be really concerned with
what appears to be a retrograde status
significantly additional discharges now
and it's the Press has been full of it
and we all need to be really concerned
as to why this is happening and whether
we ourselves can do even a little bit to
try to to rectify this and to get back
on on the right track uh councilor
Lindsay made reference to how much the
store is is used in Sudbury but it's all
along the river
particularly since since covered and
the the initial ban or reduction in
overseas travel back in 2020 we've seen
a huge uh step change in the use of the
river in this in the summertime
all along whether it's viewers Neyland
or in my patch on the Stratford St Mary
dead and Border there are vast numbers
of people now and you see the river is
full of children at teenagers and adults
all swimming there and they have a right
to to swim in very in clean water not in
polluted water they have a right not to
have their health compromised by by
swimming in in the river
uh Council Lindsay's right the we don't
have
um many teeth in this but what we can do
is to encourage and if if by passing
this motion and enacting the the points
that it references if we can encourage
angling water to to step up uh and step
up their game and do as much as possible
to to try to rectify the situation and
reduce these discharges because there's
no excuse for it happening now this is
that the third decade of the 21st
century thank you madam chairman
thank you Council Ward we will now move
to debate
councils will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
would anyone like to open a debate
counselor
thank you madam chair
I've taken a lot of interest in this
my development
thanks
to councilor Lindsay for launching the
subject and the council award for
seconding it because it is an apolitical
match and it should be
um one of the bodies to which I'm
appointed by this council is the joint
overview and scrutiny flood management
committee or a joint scrutiny flood
management subcommittee
reporting to Suffolk County Council
some of what's in this is contained
within the motion some of what we we do
on that subcommittee as a representative
from each of the constituent Suffolk
councils we receive reports from
environment agency and angular water
the process we're very aware of the
limitations that councilor Lindsay's
referred to in terms of what's allowed
statutory
but we have this ridiculous situation
where anglian water are at the same time
as they are
releasing sewage and or untreated fluid
or semi-treated sewage because that
shouldn't be overlooked they're also got
extraction licenses to take water out of
the rivers apply their own very services
I would ask that when we consider this
that we also consider the local flood
Management Authority at Suffolk County
Council does have some degree of input
into our planning reports and I think we
can quite reasonably
ask as well as asking angling water and
perhaps the environment agency as well
as scrutinizing we can also ask our
local flood Authority to provide the
information that they have available
we have a silo two separate silence here
so when this motion was launched I
wondered well we are sort of doing that
but it's not obviously being appreciated
across the board that would also give
strength to other local authorities to
adopt similar motions to bring this to
public attention
larger sporting this obviously
macro councilor beer
thank you madam chairman
um cancer Lindsay um I I support
basically all what you're the question
here
um I wanted to put a question to him but
as we're into played after wearing a
little round like that
um
item four
um Power paragraph four uh request that
Canon officers from now onwards include
in all reports relating to Major debt
development blah blah blah
um we as planners understand major
developments and I'm assuming your talk
and that it would be 15 dwellings or
more is a major development but the
public out there
you know if it's two or three it's
amazing it could be a major development
to them I understand that and I'm sure
you do but I think we need to clarify
that point to make it quite clear
otherwise we're going to have
um members of the public people who want
to come forward and support or object to
a plan application and they'll be saying
well you know major development to
dwellings being built next door to me is
Major it affects my and blah blah blah
so can can you answer that question
please that's all right thank you madam
chairman thank you Council Lindsay would
you like to clarify this point
um well I'm happy I don't know if it's
I mean if if it's
if it's going to be a problem I'm happy
to say
major development brackets
more than 15.
um close brackets but um I'm not sure
it's vital
um because I think
I think the the people who need to enact
this the planning officers will know
will know what it means
and it can be explained to our to our
residents so um
do you want to keep it as it is or or
add an amendment
I
think just put in Brackets
um
15 or more
exactly possible Council award
um is that Amendment uh something that
you'd be happy to accept
it
thank you so we'll progress the motion
with that Amendment
um
so I next have a
um
comment from counselor
no counselor next
councilor Huron thank you
chairman thank you good evening yes of
course we all should support this it's
absolutely awful
we're not the worst affected in some of
the sewers in London traces of polio and
typhoid have been fined if it passes
through us enough times and is untreated
um we are in trouble but I'm just asking
or thrown into the mix are we saying the
right things to the right people because
um
we do have um a controller of water I a
regulator in off what
and while we can't complain
with much effect to Anglia water because
obviously um they have different
priorities to what we do seem like there
is a body that's meant to regulate the
water and how it's treated in off what
and
if enough complaints go in I would have
thought their Duty burned to do
something about it so what I fully
support this motion and um not so sure
about 15 and if it's a problem there's a
problem in one house then that's as
important as 15. why fix a ceiling it
should be any house or any leakage if
it's already fallen causing the problem
well then one house is one more too many
isn't it so I wouldn't be in favor of
the 15 but I'm just wondering if we're
approaching this um from the right angle
when there does seem a regulatory body
already they may be a crango a bit
toothless but it would seem to me the
first place to start and honestly would
welcome comments from the floor on that
thank you chairman
thank you councilor Huron councilor
Davis
yeah I think it's uh important to
support this motion I I'm particularly
concerned
um with the sewage plants
the developments and I've got one in
Kansas Ward coming up for nearly 50
houses which would pass any threshold
for a major development and a recent
meeting uh nearly 100 people villagers
came to discuss this and The Surge was
was a priority for them because
publicity Nationwide has been pointed
out people are more and more aware of
the problems with sewage being into
Outlets the storm drains going into the
rivers I've got the stair obviously
right right down the bottom of our Hill
where we can see and people go in there
they bathe the paddle boarding so it's
important for them to know where the
sewage is going and I think that we
should be as firm as we can when it is
the planning meetings the Anglia water
is statutory Consultants so therefore
maybe we can include asking this
question when the officers are asking
them for their basic um
the basic things about you know what do
you think of this about the suds and
everything but have that in there as
well as saying and where will the sewage
treatment go especially when you're so
close to a river thank you
councilor Busby
next year I think just um Peter should
know better major development is not
just housing
all kinds of things so I think it's
unless you're going to specify everyone
I think we just leave major development
up to the planners they know what's a
major development because they decide
whether it needs to come to the planning
committee or not
foreign
[Music]
there is a definition of major
development in our jlp it's picked out
from the nppf IT addresses
um
employment sites as well I think from
memory it's 10 houses or more and
and I think for employment sites it's
thousand square meters or more
or more than an acre a hectare rather I
think
so what I'm saying is this ought to be
consistent with the definition that
we've already got that the government
has given us for major development
yes yeah so it's not 15 it's tenths so
in that case we have an amendment to the
amendment
you're happy with that
I'm happy with the revised connection
please sorry
I'm happy with the revised Amendment and
that we should follow the major
development definition and set out the
mbpf
um and I can supply in the precise
wording to the corporate manager which
I'll do straight away
continue with the debate councilor
Hinton
thank you madam chair yes I would also
like to uh endorse this this motion uh I
met some people in mandatory not so long
ago
who were part of the star Wild Water
swimmers and they said that they're not
swimming in the store because it's too
polluted
um so there's a bit of a problem and to
take take the example that's been given
by other members that's 244 houses
proposed in my Village
angling water have said there's no
problem there's no problem with the
pipes but what happens when it gets to
the sewage Farm which is only about
500 yards from the river
so that's and that's where the pollution
is coming from at the lower part of the
store so it is important that we have
something to do with this probably the
only it's going to be a bit toothless is
this motion because it's beyond our sort
of scope to lay down the law as far as
it is concerned but if it helps to
influence the government to tell off
what to reduce its targets for water
authorities even more because at the
moment it only reduces them a little bit
at a time
um and hopes that that will keep people
quiet without the water authorities
jumping up and down too much then if it
gets them to reduce it even further then
that's what should happen because it's
up to the water authorities to stop this
abuse of a system that was put in to
prevent problems and water backing up
sewers when there was times of extreme
rainfall they're now using it just as a
normal
position to effectively Dodge putting it
through their sewage farms and reduce
their costs
thank you councilor Hinton Council Rossi
um you had said before that you wanted
to actually speak whereas before you
were answering a particular question do
you still want to um speak on this
motion yeah just to pick up a couple of
things
um
to do with um what councilor Hinton has
mentioned
um I don't think that this is aimed at
the ordinary operation of sewage
treatment plants if I'm I think I'm
right and I'm looking at councilor
Lindsay here this is in in times when
there are storms and the drains are full
of storm water and sewage is having to
be discharged basically a valve is
opened
a discharge searing
seaweed direct into Watercourse is that
right
just say yes or no
half right okay
we shall carry on yeah yeah okay the
other point was the the point that I
think the councilor Huron made and it's
similar
um where he said that you know it
affects a single or two dwellings why
don't we why do we say major development
10 or more
um I I don't think that this type of
provision is likely to be in place for a
small development of two three four five
houses because I don't think there's
likely to be the issue on that small
General drainage issues that's storm
water drainage and sewage which is
likely to to lead to the problem
and lastly I mean at whilst I I will be
supporting this um several members
probably know that I I have
expressed my uncertainty over what we
will actually be able to achieve and I
think councilor Ward mentioned it that
we don't really have teeth
um to to
Force anything with regard to whether it
be changes to the design of developments
or whether it be changes to the existing
situation that's in in place so I think
it would be unreasonable if any of us
expected if the general public expected
us to to
get some
serious significant change as a result
of this but
um it's better than doing nothing I
think is is probably your argument and
and that I I support
thank you Council agency councilman of
easy
um I agree with the motion
and I will be supporting it
um but what I would like to point out is
that we live in a very beautiful part of
England
and part of our economy is based on
tourism
and no tourist wants to go swimming
in a river that has floating sewage
going past it
I've experienced a floating sewage
abroad and it is not very very pleasant
its way towards you
some of our rivers and estuaries and
coastal areas are rated as good
but a few are also bad
but most are below standard and that is
totally inadequate for where we live
but it's also inadequate for a country
that is supposed to be civilized
and did away with sewage being thrown
out the window many many moons ago
but the issue has a knock-on effect
because if a child ingests sewage
there are all sorts of parasites
contained in there whether that's human
sewage or animal sewage
and it can lead to illness disease and
at worst death
but it's not just one entity
it's a group of people and in my opinion
they're playing rugby with a ball which
is called who's responsible for the
sewage
I agree with councilor Huron that I
think we have to have a multi-faceted
approach
and I think we should have the teeth to
Lobby our MPS and if necessary use the
media to fight our cause
thank you madam chairman
thank you councilman of easy are there
any further questions about further
additions to this debate
thank you
um councilor Lindsay
um first of all did you you're happy to
proceed
um with the figures that
cancer didn't see um
come Council Ward
um
put forward
yeah well I thought I was withdrawing my
Amendment so it's the original motion
style yeah so we're back to the original
yeah lovely original wording which just
says major
and then we don't have to worry about
the changing definitions of
so it's currently it is 15 the current
planning applications it is 15.
obviously the jlp announces 10. so is
there anything else you would like to
add in summary no I I think I think
everyone's
to thank everyone for their contribution
and hopefully support and you know I
think I think some telling points were
made so I don't think I have anything
else to to add thank you thank you so in
that case
um I'll ask the corporate manager
governments and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for counselors to cast their vote
cancer beer can I take your vote please
I support thank you thank you
foreign
Adrian Osborne are you having technical
difficulties
questions can I take your boat
thank you
chair that that is 25 votes for the
motion
thank you so that's carried the motion
is carried
so now we'll move on to item 10B
consider the motion on notice receive
from councilor Ward
Council horde would you like to move
your motion
uh yes uh thank you madam chairman and
just a bit of background first of all
um we all know that um that there's a
considerable amount of evidence of the
impact of abuse intimidation and
aggression at a national level towards
our MPS and um obviously the the
horrible extreme incidents such as the
murder of Joe Cox and Sir David Amos
um but following on the the LGA in order
to understand the impact on local
government councilors the LJ launched a
call for evidence back in October last
year
as a result of that it has prepared a
report of its findings
and I just wanted to quote uh
a few comments from the the uh the
executive summary for this report
states that quite rightly the councilors
are at the center of local democracy
they are elected from amongst their
local community form a vital link
between councils and residents
and it is a privilege and a
responsibility to be elected to public
office as we all know
but the increasing levels of abuse and
intimidation in political and public
discourse are definitely having a
negative impact on politicians and also
by extension on Democracy at both the
local and the national level
now the right to object and to have
constructive challenge are key
components of democracy
but in abuse and intimidation do cross
the line into unacceptable behavior and
they actually serve to silence
Democratic voices and and we we are
starting to see this deter people from
engaging with politics
so as a result of this report at its
annual conference at the end of June the
LGA
initiated a campaign a debate not hate
campaign
and it's encouraging councils up and
down the country to pass a model motion
which uh effectively
asks councils to to do a number of
things to help to counteract the worst
impact of of what's going on out there
and to to act as as really a a beacon so
that the public do realize that some
behavior is not accepted and that that
we do have a role to play in trying to
to moderate that that behavior so
consequently we've got this Motion in
front of us today
um you've all had a chance to to read it
uh I don't wish to to go through it uh
in detail but I think we need to support
the LGA in their campaign
and by passing this motion this evening
will show that support
oh and just one statistic I do want to
leave you with and I think I have
mentioned it in in Council before now
in the past year 70 of councilors up and
down the country have have reported
suffering from abuse and intimidation 70
percent that's a ridiculously high
number what something's got to be done
to stop this thank you madam chairman
because
I'm gonna have a second there please
Council carpondale thank you
so we can now
um debate this item
oh sorry councilor Carpenter did you
want to speak
yes I might as well uh chairman thank
you yeah thank you councilor carpindale
sorry
uh yes I mean the uh the model motion I
think covers the ground uh it makes us
start and I think we're all aware that
one of our members here was on the
receiving end of a very unpleasant
delegation at his home some time ago
um
we seem to be living in a climate where
aggression is becoming the norm both in
society and in all levels of government
and and whilst argument and disagreement
are fine that's what politics are about
uh the kind of behavior we're seeing is
really just not acceptable
um I'm thankful that I'm not one of the
70 so far that Council award has
referred to but it's really getting
quite ridiculous that people should be
on the receiving end are so much bad
behavior
I think by and large um we counselors
are local people we look after our local
patch we protect we defend we promote
our local areas
but we also do have to take decisions
sometimes of a strategic nature that
crossed the district and unfortunately
that's not going to please everybody
every time
so you can be almost certain that
somebody's going to want to come after
you if you make a decision that they
don't like
um having said that
um it doesn't mean that's an excuse for
intimidation and bad behavior and I'm
pleased that Cancer Ward has brought
this to to the council and I'm certainly
very happy to second the motion
thank you councilor carpondale
well now I'm open this up to debate
councils will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this
and would anyone like to open the debate
Council Melanie Barrett
a question we haven't had are we not
going to take any questions because
there is uh the final bullet point is
take a zero tolerance approach to abuse
and I wondered
uh if Cancer Ward would be able to tell
us what that was but um I can wait until
I finish speaking I I think I'll allow a
question on this to clarify it okay if
you're able to cancel a ward
it is it is just that we we will not
tolerate any kind of abuse of any
counselor or officer and immediately it
happens we will do whatever we can if at
all possible to um to um
not prevents obviously the abuse could
be sort of taken place but to do
something to ensure that it doesn't
happen again
um it's very difficult to know what uh
precisely what actions can can be taken
um
and it depends on on the nature of the
abuse
sometimes it's it's something that
perhaps the monetary officer can deal
with sometimes it's it's going to have
to involve the police and I've had to
involve the police on two occasions
successfully thankfully but um it is it
is not a question of three strikes and
you're out it's a question of one strike
and you're out we will not allow us you
to get away with it just just the ones
if anyone does do something that
transgresses or crosses the line then we
need to act on upon it immediately
whether it's the council acting upon it
or whether it's us as individuals making
sure we do it ourselves
[Music]
Awards spoke earlier and he's he's
warned about he spoke about the um
negative impact that Hayes and abused
can have and like that uh struck chord
and I think with a lot of us
um
we have the councilor code of conduct we
have the Nolan principles and now we've
got this to add to the the Arsenal
um I believe there's also the Online
safety bill it hasn't hasn't finally had
a final reading yet so it's looking at
these issues in the population but we
still have this problem
um
thankfully the vast majority of people
are respectful and tolerant when coming
face coming into contact face to face I
think I think the problem is often when
it's online
um
where comments can be seen and
replicated to a wide audience
um you can't tell where your your
comments are going to end up you you
can't control it once it once it's out
there
um
just a that quick click of a mouse and
the hateful comment reduces and debases
politics to the gutter
um
I am mindful of recent events when I
when I speak about this because it has
um affected us on this side of the the
chamber enormously
um so I hope you all agree that it's
incompetent all councilors here to
personally take responsibility for
social media use
the we are Community leaders
I think the greatest way to
bring about change in the community is
by example and by censure by your own
peer group
um so I hope you agree that that is
something we all need to be very aware
of
anyone else want to join the debate
oh cancel beer
thank you madam chairman
um well
you'll be very not hate it's a Pity we
didn't have this before us a couple of
meetings ago and we may not have had the
problems we had a couple of meetings ago
when we weren't allowed to debate an
issue
and there was certainly hatred felt on
this side of the chamber
um and we think you were badly advised
at the time to Guillotine to meet him
and to allow
certain counselors to say things about
another counselor who was in the room
and wasn't allowed to defend herself
I think that's very important
and hate is how we interpret it enough
necessaried of the Chamber from what
happened then and I take
um note of what counselor cartandale was
saying 70 percent uh I think I most
likely am in in that now
I believe after that
council meeting a couple of meetings ago
I've been named in the paper and called
names and what have you all right so you
could all say after all these years but
it's like they shouldn't be called some
names but I don't like it more than any
of you and I wouldn't be doing any of
that name calling so I think
that uh the people Behind These should
realize that there is still this feeling
of hate
um that we we have that has come out
because after all
we asked you to support us on a
particular issue and the majority of you
chose to support
the uh the person who we felt was behind
this and it wasn't right in our opinion
so debate
not hate yes that's what should be
happening I just hope you can bring it
to bear on those people within your
group who are continuing to do this
thank you
that's a Dawson
um yes I I'm delighted to see this
motion come up
um but what I dislike if I may ask
counselor
um I'll leave it if you could absolutely
confirm there's going to be a zero
tolerance from you and all the
colleagues here on your colleagues that
are retweeting hate messages and just
trashing you know counselors and it's
all very well for us all to stand here
and say you know we'll all vote this
through but what do we do when we've got
a vice chairman
doing all this stuff under
a journalist I think this is not the
time for me I'm asking the question very
politely will there be Zero Tolerance on
retweeting hate mail and if that's a yes
on uh
that that matters now
it's a Cancer Ward
I think that's a fair question Castle
Dawson um
Zero Tolerance I I stand by what I say
this is in the lga's motion and the LGA
stands by that you are referring to a
matter that was resolved at our last
meeting it is no longer an issue it is a
matter that has been resolved and uh
we've all learned from that there were
two apologies at that last meeting we've
all learned from that as I said it's
time to move forward and to put it in
the past and so you need to remember
what I said at the time and that's the
way we're looking at it there weren't no
further recurrence of anything like that
from any member towards any other member
okay looking forward
if I may come back
no it's one one opportunity
I've been answered I'm talking about
going forward as well well no because
um you know when it's much of debate as
I said councils will be allowed to speak
once
is it Council malfeasy you're next
thank you madam chairman
um
it's interesting I think that
we have a disconnecting Society between
hate and bullying and some people do not
truly understand what hate means
um and it would have been useful to have
had that actual definition
and many people associate bullying as a
form of
and I think we need to remember
that as probably as children definitely
in my childhood Sticks and Stones might
break my bones but names will never hurt
me well that's not true
names do hurt
they hurt very much
and I
um I uphold Council award for proposing
this motion
um and I agree with councilor Barrett
that we do need to lead by example
when I first came to Suffolk
I joined the parish council
and I was very heavily bullied
and it's not pleasant
but I'm a tough old group thank you
Fraser
thank you
I'm just looking at the the motion in
hand and it seems just slightly vague to
me um all right
at writing to MPS
um right into the LGA it doesn't really
give much
substance on how to support a shall I
say a newly elected counselor what is
the guidelines what's to be expected
um
70 of us yes
um I think I fit into that number
um my recent case was more of a
harassment
um constant barrage of tautology if I
can use that great word of yours
um without going away and then moving on
to threats but not threats of harm or
violence but threats of undermining my
status threats of
complaints multiple complaints but still
won't even come in for our Collective
Amusement but I think the point I'm
trying to get out here is what supports
are we going to give newly elected
councils on top of their training we've
recently undertaken a new code of
conduct training for counselors which
put more emphasis on our bearing in the
community
and what guidelines we have to fit in
but I believe there should be
our training and guidelines for
counselors need to be reviewed at what
point can
cut off Communications what supports are
we going to get from the council
themselves to review
individual situations and advise what
should actions should be taken
so I think we should have a look a
little bit more in-house as well as how
we can support ourselves new
newly elected councilors on the next
Council as well thank you
thank you
uh councilor Davis
thank you as as the comment was clearly
directed at the uh the era of judgment
that I made some time ago when I shared
a Facebook post
um it was wrong I apologized which I was
asked to do by the monitoring officer
and I've done that and you know it's a
wrong thing to do I totally support this
motion I've never taken part in a convoy
attacking the leader's house I've never
made a rude gesture in this chamber to
the leader I've never done an awful lot
of the things that other councilors have
done I've suffered abuse myself
um I've like Council award I've had to
call the
they've acted very promptly and dealt
with the situations very efficiently
so I think there's also a case of
balance yes 0. Zero Tolerance on issues
but we need to make sure that we're
doing it for the right reasons and we
shouldn't be hiding behind other people
doing the hate message as well shouldn't
support those people by aqueous
acquiescence to their needs and demands
as well so yes total support debate not
hate
okay
thank you councilor Davis is there
anyone
cancer Barrett Simon Barrett
Davis
point the Zach Heisenberg perhaps to go
into
so there you go
we have to put up with this hypocrisy
all over the place
are there any more
people who wish to speak in this debate
um if not then um Council award I think
there are some points that counts the
phrase that you might like to answer
Council phrases points uh yes I was uh
going to do that thanks for the
opportunity Madam chairman uh Council
phrase I I totally agree we we do need
to make sure that we revise
um all of the support we give
particularly to new newly elected
councilors and we will make sure we uh
we provide additional support and
whatever we can do
um for those councilors that are going
to get elected next next May it's an
opportune moment to to review all of
that and to make sure that we've got
everything updated in time for that
and that that really brings me on to the
only other thing I wanted to see
um
the
really important that councils up and
down the land do take a stand on this
the last thing we want to do is to
dissuade people from standing for
election it's already difficult enough
to get people to stand but if this
deters more people from from standing
then
democracy will be that will suffer and
if our Democratic systems fail from the
ground up then we're going to be in a
very difficult position going forward
thank you madam chairman
thank you Council award
so now I think we'll move on to the vote
I'll ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote thank you thank you
chair that is now showing in blue for
members to cast their vote thank you
Council beer can I take your vote please
for the motion thank you
chair thank you that the votes are 24
for the motion and one against
thank you so that motion is carried
so now we're drawing to the close of the
meeting
um
so um
so so we're coming to a close to the
close of the meeting now
um just in case uh people wondered we
had mentioned pre or I had mentioned
previously a photograph
um in fact the photograph is now going
to be taken of all of us at the end of
the March meeting
um
the date of the next meeting is Tuesday
20th December at 5 30.
um it will be determined closer to the
date whether that meeting will be needed
or not
so
thank you very much all for attending
and have a good evening and I'll now
close the meeting